airbnb is is really disrupting
real estate and i know a lot about real
estate i just did a little fake business
now you know that i do this a lot of the
audience don't know that i do i do fake
business
i call up realtors all day when i'm
bored
and i pretend i'm a realtor and that my
client is very interested in their
property and i
ask them lots of questions about the
property i just did it with a commercial
property
on palm canyon drive i said hey this is
tim
uh i have a client of investor that's
really interested in the property what
are we looking at per square foot and
what are some of the local restrictions
we should know about
and you know these whole things they go
into this whole thing they go well
you know they don't want a coffee shop
in there because starbucks there's a
competing business clause
so starbucks doesn't want a coffee shop
this is how the corporate takeover of
america is by the way
because when starbucks moves into an
area they go yeah we don't need we don't
want some independent coffee shop
opening
not all areas but a lot of them we don't
need somebody slinging lattes for less
than we are so the guy goes
well there's a sprint store so we can't
do a competing business blah blah
and we talked about it there's a lot of
parking behind i said thank you i said i
have an investor but he's very concerned
about you know the competing business
clause and everything like that i was on
the phone this guy for about 10
minutes and he said to me oh tim that's
cruel their time has value
no it doesn't and i will continue to do
fake business
because i enjoy i like doing fake
business it's one of my favorite things
to do i like to call people
and i like to lie about who i am and and
and what i do
and then i like to see how they conduct
business because on their end
they're conducting real business i'm
conducting fake business
now never the two shall meet we've
gotten to the point where we're almost
one of my clients who doesn't exist was
almost going to put an offer on a house
this was last week i was i've been on
the phone with this realtor for like 45
minutes three times in a row i've had
the blocker finally she doesn't know
what happened
sometimes i have to block the people
because fake business gets very intense
fake business people start throwing up
contracts i mean she was calling
appraisers she was gonna have
inspections done you know
i'm was representing a very motivated
overseas client
now sadly that client died of
coronavirus
before we could go see the property
that's not my fault and i tried to
explain that to her
but she was kind of confused and started
saying oh this you know blah blah blah
are you real is this real cops fbi
whatever blah blah blah blocked
blocked i'm helping train these
professionals
do you understand yes or yes i by
calling them
people need practice so this schmuck
over there on palm canyon i did use my
real name by the way
like this is tim dillon and sometimes i
make up a firm name sometimes i use a
real firm name
sometimes i just say this is tim dillon
with futures he goes what like a futures
investment
he goes okay you just go okay go yeah
all right
i go yeah you got a commercial listing
on palm canyon on the corner
i'm wondering what we're looking at
price per square foot what's the parking
area like
what's the competing business clause
well any local restrictions we should
know about
i have a team of investors that are
looking to expand into this area many of
them uh
sometimes it's a franchise sometimes not
but i'm just you know it's an investment
group they're very interested they love
the visibility of the location oh he
goes it's a great location
so they love the visibility of the look
and see right there we're beginning to
do
fake business because then he goes to
his wife and goes
i just got a call from a guy that may be
interested in this and then he tells the
secretary and then he tells his partner
so i'm in i'm in and i'll give him a
follow-up call later tonight i'll have
10 more bullet point questions
before i bring my investiture and i do
this a lot of people
i was explaining to someone at dinner
that i did i do this
and it goes it's horrible i said why
i'm doing fake business they go why i
said i
like doing it so i don't have a real
estate license
and i can't do real business but i at
least can do fake business
they said that's pretty sick i said
maybe you're sick
because i want realtors to get the best
professional
i want your golf a lot right when you
golf when you golf every day are you
better at it
yes absolutely now that doesn't matt now
even that includes going to a driving
range sure
right correct right sometimes i see
golfers swing clubs in their backyard
helps helps doesn't matter if it's real
or fake
what matters is that this guy's going
through the moat the next guy to call
him might be real
but i'm going to beat that guy out i'm
going to do a competitive
offer because i conduct fake business
well
and many people don't a lot of people do
things
people go on fake diets i've done a ton
of them people do all kinds of things
that aren't real
people are fake comedians they pretend
to be a comedian
for a decade and impoverish themselves
and live on a floor and walk dogs
fine that's all when you go home
to your family for thanksgiving and you
go i'm a comedian
they're eating and they're like no
you're not you're a pretend community
you're a fake comedian
i am a fake real estate investor and i i
will continue to do fake business
so if you get a call from a guy that
sounds like me
just be forewarned the deal's not
closing
the deal's not closing i have an
interest
in presenting myself i have a lot of
clients when i do fake business
they're very busy many of them are
overseas
they cannot handle i mean we should
probably get the phone do a little fake
business right now
maybe we get our phone can you get the
phone let's do a little fake business
because i don't think people understand
what i bring to the table and how good i
really am
do you have my is that my phone let me
call this guy back
how did we get him in the road casper is
he in the road caster
hello hey adam tim dillon how are you we
spoke about the property on palm canyon
a few minutes ago
yeah hey tim how's it going good buddy
how are you i wanted to know if there's
a list of
the the competing clause uh my client's
asking me if there's a list of
businesses whether it's starbucks sprint
things like that
that we could kind of figure out what
the restrictions are just so i could
kind of email that to them because he
wants to show it to the
his investors if that's possible also is
there a way they can get out to see the
proper
property maybe later in the week
yeah yeah i live about four minutes from
it so not too
difficult um that and um
uh i will just go to the center right
now and send you a quick list of all
the businesses that are out there all
right i would appreciate that let me ask
you a question too how long has this
property been on the market i have i
haven't looked it up yet
yeah i've been marketing it for maybe i
think
i just signed it like right when covet
hit and then i delayed it for like
two or three months so i think maybe
like two or three months now okay and
what before you had it was it was it
sitting there for a while or no they
always like to know these things
yeah i don't i know banner mattress was
there up until recently
um so i know there's a mattress
right across the street yeah i saw that
is this would this be a five year lease
or what what are we what are they
looking for in terms of
commitment yeah really just depends on
the
the tenant and the rate and things like
that obviously the longer
the commitment the better we can do on
the rate
um but um you know i think they're open
right now
okay and and i imagine they're never
five years down i imagine they're open
to some form of negotiation
at you know given the climate of course
okay well i appreciate that we're here
to do deals yeah
me too but i mean me too it's a little
wild out there
you know are you guys mainly commercial
you do any residential
um i do a bit of both okay good yeah you
got to be kind of a generalist out here
i agree a lot of people are starting to
get interested in this area and i think
it's because
you know la's had a lot of problems and
a lot of
a lot of my clients i do business
primarily in in los angeles
and a lot of people are starting to look
at this area
and um you know a lot of them are are
excited about maybe jumping into
uh something here you know because the
high season i imagine it's what january
through
through june uh yeah january through
april is our high high season right um
but we're pretty much like right now
like september through
april um you know so we have kind of we
kind of have like a shoulder mid season
uh which is september through december
right um and then january
april just crushes and then uh coachella
is obviously
in stagecoach earned april and that kind
of you know
and we have a memorial day weekend july
4th and during the summer we do pretty
well
of course i appreciate that well listen
i have you guys i have your website
i'm going to shoot you an email um just
again introducing myself and then if you
could just get me a list of some of
those competing business clauses just so
i can show it to them
and uh hopefully they'll get out to see
it sometime uh next week you know
they're they're super interested
one of them lives out here in rancho and
uh they pass it all the time so
they had me just kind of reach out to
you and see what was going on but
they're pretty motivated and again i
think it's all about you know how
restrictive those clauses are
yeah i think they're going to be pretty
flexible so i'll shoot you the
businesses
yes and uh we'll see if we can do
something okay i appreciate it adam
thanks a lot for your time
all right thank you so it's fake
business
and i'm doing it well i'm doing it well
let's be honest i'm doing it well
i'm protecting the interest of my
clients
i'm pretty am i not am i not protecting
the interest of my clients
when i conduct fake business my
fake clients are important and they need
to be
protected i want them to have the
maximum amount of freedom
in any given situation you understand
start doing fake business it'll change
your life i'm telling you that right now
start doing it no one can start you
don't need a license
you just need a phone and a computer
and you can start doing fake business
set up a fake email address i have one
start doing fake business right now it's
the gateway to real business
are you bored are you sitting around
at home you don't know what to do build
a fake empire of whatever business you
choose
you don't need any type of license to do
this
you can just call people and
be the person you've always been meant
to be i think i've always meant to be
sort of a rainmaker putting together
deals
a guy with a six-pack and a huge [ __ ]
[ __ ] people of every gender doesn't
matter
maybe connected to intelligence maybe
not power broker type of guy
and that's what i now of course i'm not
that
i'm negotiating commercial real estate
mattress transactions or rancho mirage
it doesn't only fake business doesn't
always work out the way you wanted to
i wanted to be fake cia i can't do that
but i'm a fake realtor in the [ __ ]
desert
even your fake life will not be as great
you see even you're pretending even in
my pretend life
i'm just a shitty realtor looking to
sniff out a bach
but i know who i am i know who i am in
my real life and my fake life and that's
what's the most important thing
set the expectations for your fake
business
high but reasonable this is my advice to
you
gary vaynerchuk tells you to start a
real business oh i say no no
i say start a fake one start a pretend
business
you can do everything that you will do
in a real business there's much less
risk
sure these people get upset after a
while after you've called him 17 or 18
times
you have to make up stories about what
happened to your investor why didn't you
show up to the showing
you were in the hospital it's easy to do
i'm just telling you it's important oh
tim these people's time is valuable no
it's not
no it's not they love it all they do all
day is talk to 90 people one of them
signs a contract i'm one of the fake
people
until the contract is signed all
business for intents and purposes
is fake business
and i am one of the best that's what
i've been doing here to keep myself sane
[Music]
i mean right now i'm negotiating a strip
mall in connecticut
you see that's much more
it's much more complex because there's
many different
storefronts you see see what i mean
as you get better at fake business you
have to start looking things up you got
to know tax numbers you got to know
profit and loss i mean you got to really
know your stuff
if you want to start talking to real i
have some real deal people i talk to
they're legit they make real money and
they think i'm a realtor
you know they think i represent an
investment group
so that's what i think you should do if
i had to choose how you spend your time
it would be that